Schaben beseitigen Vogelkot wegkratzen
Waschbären vertreiben und jede Menge
Blut wegwischen wenn jemand gestorben
ist sofort tot oder
ich habe mich nie darum gekümmert wäre
eigentlich die ganze dreckige Arbeit für
uns übernimmt jetzt bin ich eine Woche
Schädlingsbekämpfer und tatortreinigerin
[Musik]
ich möchte wissen wie hart es ist die
Arbeit zu machen die
das sind meine neuen Kollegen
Jörn
Nina
Sergej
und Silvia
und das bin ich aus lieg
eigentlich arbeite ich als Reporterin
bei Bild ist gestorben lag vielleicht
länger hat sich erschossen umgebracht
damit ihr meine Geschichte dahinter
[Musik]
[Applaus]